okay um yes so my name is spencer frye
um today i'll talk about proxy convexity
a unified framework for the analysis of
neural network extreme by gradient
descent
and most of this is going to be joint
work with my phd advisor chon chong gu
at ucla
so just kind of an overview of the type
of stuff that i'm interested in thinking
about and that i've been thinking about
for the past few years has just been
motivated by trying to understand the
success of neural networks trained by
gradient descent it's like concretely
like when and why do neural networks
strain by gradient descent generalize
well to unseen data
so understanding this kind of requires
grappling with the non-complexity of the
optimization problem as well as kind of
you know understanding the
generalization performance and more uh
standard questions and statistical
learning theory
and the particular approach that i've
i've been taking is trying to kind of
study the problem from the bottom up
in the sense of like what can we
explicitly show that a neural network
that is trained by gradient descent will
provably generalize like what type of
assumptions on the data
what type of assumptions on the
architecture and then the gradient
descent algorithm do we need in order to
say that neural networks during migraine
descent will generalize um and a
particular interest is you know when the
data is noisy like how can we because
you know they're the most interesting
parts of
uh neural networks seem to appear when
when there's noise in the labels right
the fact that you can interpolate and
still generalize is one of the most
perplexing
problems so that's something i've
tried to pay a lot of attention to
so just some of these distributions
where we
have shown that
it can a neural network chambered a
gradient sound can generalize
is like a noisy half space where some of
the labels are corrupted
you have some
you know single neuron that generates
the data that has some some
arbitrary noise added to it and then
some some new work that's going to be
coming out is on this kind of noisy xor
problem
and just to kind of
note is that each of these do not
involve the neural tangent kernel
analysis so there is something that's
beyond this kind of kernel regime that
uh that lynn was talking about before
so you know in in doing this analysis
you run into some issues if you try to
apply kind of standard non approaches in
non-complex optimization for these
problems
um because in many of these instances
there are local minima which are not
global minima and so the kind of
standard approaches for showing like the
pl inequality or restricted secant
or any like number of standard
non-convex optimization properties
will generally fail because they just
won't hold
and so like this is even evident in the
most simple non-linear neural networks
there are like a single relu neuron
so a lot of work over the past few years
has showed that even this problem itself
has a number of hardness constraints on
it if you wanted to try to find the best
fitting single neuron over a data set
with gaussian marginals even
that's going to be a hard problem
but what we can show is that
gradient descent does find something
that's maybe not the best but it is
something that's like
somewhat close to the best um
at least in terms of what are the
hardness constraints for the learning
problem in general
and so this kind of
you know
motivates you know what
ideally we would be able to have some
type of non-convex optimization
framework that is
applicable to lots of settings in neural
networks
and ideally we would have some type of
properties that we could describe that
says you know if these prop if
property x y and z are satisfied
then you can just call some kind of
textbook optimization analysis that will
say that you'll have this optimization
and learning guarantee
and ideally you know over the past five
years there's been a lot of work on
showing provable guarantees for neural
networks strain by gradient descent
but you know they're kind of disparate
it's not clear what is the kind of
unifying view of these and ideally a
framework would be a new framework would
be able to do so
um and so this kind of motivates one of
the first in a series of definitions
around like what we call proxy convexity
and so proxy a function we call to proxy
convex um so if there are these two
proxy functions h and g that end up
satisfying something close to convexity
um so these functions h and g are going
to be related to the original objective
function f
and the way you can think about it is
just that the standard convexity in
terms of the function lying above
the first order taylor approximation
maybe that doesn't hold but there are
these two other functions h and g
such that the function h lies above the
first order taylor approximation
and maybe it's shifted down a little bit
uh so that it's not f where you're
starting from but some function g
right and so it's a bit abstract and you
know it's not uh
it's not immediately clear like why this
abstraction might be useful but what you
can show is that if you have uh guaran
you know if you if this type of property
is satisfied then you can show that this
proxy function g is at least as small as
the proxy function h and so the task
then is to kind of
show that proxy complexity holds for
some functions g and h that are relevant
to the problem at hand
and then you can kind of just call these
off-the-shelf guarantees that will say
that you'll have optimization or
generalization at this type of rate
um and so this came you know one local
statement or how global of a statement
uh it could be local uh it's more that
there exists a function v such that this
this holds um
or there exists a vector v such that
that holds um but you can frame it in
terms of global it's it's kind of it's
flexible like i wrote it here for for it
being all v and w but it's really that
there exists a v such that this holds
um
so for something like i know that this
is true
yes
so
it's true for this for this single
neuron problem um and you can show that
it's true in a bunch of in the bunch of
the neural tangent kernel literature
that's come up you can see that this is
true
in some of the feature learning
literature you can see it this is true i
mean the task it's really it's hard to
say what exactly these functions h and g
are until you kind of get into the guts
of what what these optimization things
are
um i mean i think
that much use h and g as your predictor
uh
so so say that again it's been real
enough to be using hmq i've got
something which is close to the neural
net above and below
why do i care about the neural net i
don't know if hng are easier to optimize
in some sense maybe they're a
regularized version of the neural net
maybe they'll actually perform better
yeah that's that's possible um i'm not
it's not it's not clear to me
i haven't tried explicitly uh optimizing
these news hng
uh
because i mean the the interest in in
developing this this for me was to say
like you know we know that neural
networks do you know that they work
and so what is the kind of optimization
properties that are implicitly allowing
for such things to happen
um and it's possible that you could
formulate it explicitly so that uh maybe
it's a bit more direct there
but
yes i mean so i mean
the functions end up looking a bit weird
in different settings like this is the
simplest setting which is like a single
neuron
and you have these derivatives end up
being attached to the function to the
losses that you're typically looking at
um
and this is what allows for getting
these guarantees for single neural and
strain by gradient descent
but it's a very it's a very
problem-specific analysis that ends up
that you know there doesn't seem to be a
unifying
g and h for for different network
architectures but it does seem that
there are g and h such that such things
hold in many settings
um so there's another version of this
proxy convexity in terms of a proxy pl
inequality
um so the standard pl inequality bounds
the gradient from below by the
difference in the function value to the
smallest possible value
um and so this this variant of it
converts that lower bound to something
that's actually just the difference
between this proxy function g
and this uh kind of slack error term psi
and what's beneficial about this is that
you know uh
you might not this this the fact that
this slack error term is not just the
global minimum allows for the
possibility that there are local minima
that are not
uh global and what does this actually
look like in
uh you know
things that we have actually been able
to show
uh so if you have some half space that
has labels that have been corrupted
uh you can show that there is this proxy
loss which is
just the negative derivative of the
logistic loss which if you write it out
as the sigmoid loss
and then the slack error term is the
amount of label noise in the problem
first you know approximately the amount
of label noise in the problem
and so showing this type of property
means that all stationary points will
have
you know error that's at most
proportional to the label noise this
leaves open the question of what happens
after you end up interpolating but it
does at least give you a better idea of
what's going on in the beginning of
trading
um and just to kind of summarize uh the
goal of this kind of framework was to
put forward a definition of a non-convex
optimization framework that can
accommodate
uh problems where local minima are not
global but that they are at least good
and something i didn't have time to go
into today was the kind of numerous
results over the past couple years
that have been able to show provable
guarantees for neural network stream by
gradient descent
and how they might fit into this
framework of proxy convexity and proxy
pl on the
quality and uh
[Applause]
all right thanks um
what is next
i know one of one of our speakers may be
remote i